Donald Trump has won in Ohio and we can
now paint that red now still been still
bad we're gonna get to that question in
a second we just have a little bit of
action here yeah still the map that I
developed is still spot on for right now
nothing has changed right now versus my
map for now that's all I'm saying
right okay yeah I don't know what's
going to have decision decision desk HQ
not only called Ohio but they're calling
Florida Missouri North Carolina for
Donald Trump I can definitely see
Florida I think we've already called
Missouri a little bit earlier than yet
North Carolina was still out but there I
I don't have anything to say but yes
every morning when I start my show
I don't know how America I don't know
how the office of the presidency
survives Donald Trump yeah because the
the sheer disdain that we're he's going
to be shown I mean what they did to
President Obama over the last eight
years it's a house in comparison for
what we're getting ready to do to Donald
Trump but yeah I mean if the role of the
presidency it's it's it's really going
to devolve into something that I don't
know I don't know if there's gonna be
any respect left for the office once
he's gone
a first lady who is working illegally in
the United States at one point right I
mean you can't write this stuff I'm
sorry we got off track we just we I
think that it's too early to have the
answers to exactly how this is all going
to play out you know we're all sort of
trying to process the results right now
so we'll deal with that I guess tomorrow
morning thank you so much for the call
we're going to keep looking at what it
is that is happening here but Ohio has
been called for Donald Trump and we now
also are seeing it it appears as though
we are getting closer to a Florida call
because 95 percent is reporting there we
know that it seems like corporate media
likes to wait until they call Florida
because of what's happened ever since
the year 2000 they like to wait on
Florida but it is not looking very good
in Florida no no I mean I've already you
know I mean there's really no reason
they haven't gone ahead and called this
there are only like three district three
counties four counties that are
democratic-leaning
yeah and
those have reported at a 95 96 98
percent yeah there's nothing left for
Hillary Clinton to get in Florida yep I
agree with you all right let's take a
call from Gibbon Gibbon is joining us
given where are you calling from okay
I'm having a super hard time hearing the
caller's I don't know if you are Ben
maybe we can bump them up a little bit
you said you're calling from New
Hampshire
yes and Hodson cool what can we do for
you so I'm wondering what are you
thoughts on Trump's policies on
immigration I think they're a disaster
and I think they're completely
hypocritical and I think they're
unrealistic Mexico's not going to pay
for a wall his own wife was working in
the United States illegally before she
was legally authorized here she is
someone that is on the list of people
who should have been deported according
to trump based on his own deportation
force ideas I think that they're a
complete joke Ben what is there more to
say no that's it can I ask something
else too
sure yeah my name is Adam to make from
nine gambia shriek come assassin the
doors open my name is Reid Hudson New
Hampshire come kill me Adam Dobek my
mom's names yeah okay well I couldn't
understand her myself a prank called
connoisseur yeah I relish a good prank
call and I don't know what these calls
are about like what is the joke do you
know Pat maybe it's like I'm too old to
understand what the jokes are I think
the warning sign was when he said he
wants to say something else yeah that's
never good whenever I want to say
something else
you know no I should have known because
it was quite the lame question to be
think about Donald Trump's immigration
policies well no [ __ ] Sherlock what do
you think we yeah they're a disaster
yeah okay let's take a call from 805 805
you were on the line with us named and
where you're calling from hi um this is
Mackenzie calling from Seattle
Washington all right yeah at all I think
still maybe Hillary can win if we're
lucky
maybe maybe I had a question about the
next election cycle yeah so this
election has been about voting for the
other candidate so my question is do you
think that this kind of polarization is
unique to this election
or this the future is this the future of
American politics I believe that we are
seeing a change to American politics
it's been pretty effed up for a while
then yeah but I think it's getting worse
I think that this does signify a change
particularly whether Trump wins or loses
the fact that he's just the nominee
signifies a change for American policy
the fact that it's this close
yeah the nominee just the fact that he
got them well actually I want to I mean
some of the nomination came as a result
of all the free media I mean you don't
get two billion to some estimates above
the three billion dollars of free media
yeah and not win a nomination but the
fact that the race is this close tells
you how many people are willing to play
ball with Donald Trump style politics no
doubt Gary no doubt did you vote today
by the way Mackenzie I did yes
voted yesterday oh you voted early
voting yes Washington is all
vote-by-mail so oh that's right yeah
Washington spoke this see we need that
here in Massachusetts don't we Ben yeah
yeah thanks David so kind of related to
my first question what what type of
candidate or policies do you think could
unite the country again if you think
that something against me I wish I was a
policy that could unite the country
I think we're so far from that then I
don't know I mean I just don't know
aliens yeah I think I think some big
discovery I've talked about with neil
degrasse tyson about how significant
advancements with regard to space travel
intelligent life outside of this planet
that might be such a major uniting force
but short of that I just don't know
McKenzie I don't see any policy uniting
people okay yeah okay thank you thank
you so much for the call really really
appreciate it we are guys getting very
very close to some additional calls
there are rumblings that Virginia has
been slash is going to be called soon
depending on where you look and we will
probably be making that call in favor of
Hillary Clinton pretty soon right I mean
Virginia is starting to shape up like
what it should have been which is a win
for Hillary Clinton are you getting the
same thing yeah
yeah we're look Slyke we can go in that
direction thankfully I mean I don't know
what she would do without Virginia yeah
it would be over I think yeah she lost
Virginia there okay let's take a call
from seven five seven seven five seven
area code what's going on hey what's
going on Dean's again you know I had a
question before but I didn't I didn't
really have the chance to ask you I feel
before the election actually sort of
again a little bit but they had a video
about project bear house yeah are you
familiar I am what are you what are your
stances about them and I've heard a lot
of differentiating opinions about that
yeah well you want to take this first
Ben you see me yes
project Veritas from James O'Keefe they
are the scum of the earth I think the
only people who are more repugnant than
Donald Trump
not just in the quality of character but
definitely with how they deliver their
content highly edited to try to convince
that there's a narrative that doesn't
exist right there they're editing these
videos to make it look like it's
actually something all the way back to
the Acorn incident of 2008 James O'Keefe
is the scum of the earth and I if you
want you could cite Rush Limbaugh and be
more credible than if you cite James
O'Keefe all right I mean I could not
possibly add to that right but I mean
some of the things that they said like
why did he get fired
why did I'm not sure what his name was
but why did he resign why he'd get fired
oh that's easy I mean the he's talking
about the the the guy who was working
for the democratic-leaning organization
he retired he resigned after the video
came out because one listen
he was an imbecile to begin with right
but then too it's just they're they're
they're cutting their losses as soon as
this gets out look just look up Google
James O'Keefe and acorn and see the
number of people he got fired he took
down an entire organization with a video
that was completely fabricated that was
not true so take a look at that and you
can understand why our organization were
very quickly part ways with anyone who
shows up in a James O'Keefe video